[Musik]
auf ganz privaten Bildern gibt er sich
bescheiden dabei ist er einer der
reichsten Männer der Welt
in seinem Werk so heißt es wird der
härteste Stahl produziert
[Musik]
Alfred Krupp von Bohlen und Halbach
die Krups gelten als Waffenschmiede des
Deutschen Reiches
[Musik]
an den selbst die mächtigsten glauben
eine Mythos ist er dadurch geworden dass
es die Waffenproduktion war das war ja
nur ein Teil seiner seines Aufstiegs und
seiner Entwicklung und aber das war
natürlich das was aufgeregt hat der
Produzent von Waffen und besonders
schweren und schwerwiegenden Waffen mit
großen Kanonen und so das hat eigentlich
die Mythos gestiftet und dafür wird ihn
1947 der Prozess gemacht seine Ankläger
werfen ihn Kriegsverbrechen vor von
daher wird humanity er wurde angeklagt
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
begangen zu haben ein zweiter Punkt war
die Plünderung fremden Eigentums in den
eroberten Gebieten
Mitglied in einer kriminellen
Organisation gewesen zu sein und genau
gewusst zu haben was die Nazis für
Verbrechen planen dafür wurde Krupp
angeklagt
[Musik]
ihn bringt er kein Glück
seine erste Ehe scheitert
sie liebte nur sein Geld
seine zweite große Liebe verlässt ihn
sein Sohn Arndt wird ein Exzentriker
der in seiner eigenen Welt lebt
einer Märchenwelt in der er sich zum
Ritter schlagen lässt
dieser warm von einem Königreich ist
immerhin gewesen
das ist immer das hat sie wahrscheinlich
hat er sich eingebildet wenn er dann
grob ist an dieser König oder so
irgendwie und hat das
abgewandelt in dieses Königreich aber
das hatte ja schon vorher gehabt in der
Schule auch schon gehabt
schon als 16-Jähriger sieht Arnd sein
Schicksal vorher in sein Tagebuch
schreibt er
ich habe herausgefunden dass mich ein
Fluch verfolgt der Meinung Unglück sein
wird es ist der Fluch des Geldes
die Villa Hügel in Essen
Stammsitz der Familie Krupp
ein gigantischer Bau mit 269 Zimmern
Symbol für macht
und Einfluss
den Alfred Krupp Mitte des 19
Jahrhunderts geschaffen hat
also ich sehe Alfred immer so ein
bisschen als dieses Mittelding zwischen
Genie und Wahnsinn also der hat ja nun
ein unglaubliches unternehmerisches
Gespür an den Tag gelegt allerdings auch
an vielen Stellen also fast
hasardeurartig diese Firma
geführt und dann halt immer auch das
Quäntchen Glück dabei gehabt
denn er macht eine geniale Erfindung das
nahtlos geschmiedete eisenbahnrat es
wird das kubische Markenzeichen in der
beginnenden Industrialisierung des 19
Jahrhunderts wird die Firma zu einer
wahren Goldgrube bald beschäftigt
tausende von Arbeit
Alfred ist ja nachts durch die wegräume
gegangen und hat auf jede Werkbank an
der vorbei kam Zettelchen hinterlassen
wo drauf stand Meyer morgen machen sie
das an der nächsten Werke Müller morgen
machen sie das das Werk und die Pflicht
dafür das war eins das war sein Leben
deshalb hat seinen Arzt auch gesagt er
glaubt der Mann war an der Grenze zum
Wahnsinn
und verfällt einen neuen Idee krupp ist
der erste der Geschützrohre aus Stahl
baut
Krupp Kanonen halten länger schießen
besser
der Waffenschmied verkauft an Freund und
Feind
1870 baut er sich das Haus die Villa
Hügel
[Musik]
doch der Erfolg macht einsam seine Frau
läuft ihn Weg verlassen stirbt er 1887
und hinterlässt ein schweres Erbe auf
dem Sarkophag steht ganz groß das
höchste Gut
des Menschen ist die Pflicht und damit
gemeint die Pflicht dem Werk gegenüber
diese Pflicht wurde in die Erziehung
sämtlicher Kinder im Hause ein
geflochten vor allen Dingen in den
Erstgeborener der der Erstgeborenen
sollte später die Firma einmal
übernehmen Friedrich Alfred Krupp der
Sohn nach dem Tod des Vaters übernimmt
er die Firma
und es sind gute Zeiten für das Werk
Kaiser Wilhelm II will aufrüsten er
braucht Waffen und eine flotte
[Musik]
aus dem Stahlwerk wird ein
Industriegigant um die
jahrhundertwendearbeiten schon 45.000
Menschen für grob
doch glücklich ist Friedrich Alfred
nicht
eigentlich der falsche Mann oder in der
falschen Haut also an sich jemand der
sich für schön geistiges interessiert an
sich jemand der für ja Meeresbiologie
Naturwissenschaften sich Interessierte
und jemand der nie auf die Idee gekommen
wäre in den Stahlbereich zu gehen selber
der industrielle erholt sich in Italien
auf der Insel Capri hier macht der
Asthmatiker nicht nur Urlaub er kümmert
sich auch um Meeresforschung
doch dann kommt er ins Gerede
es soll auf Gabriel wo erlebte in einer
Grotte Kurt ähnliche Zusammenkünfte
gegeben haben mit jungen Männern und
schon die Andeutung von Homosexualität
war damals verheerend
vor allem in Deutschland
[Musik]
am 15 November 1902 behauptet die
sozialdemokratische Zeitung Vorwärts
Krupp sei homosexuell
in der Kaiserzeit ein Straftatbestand
es ist der Abend des 21 november 1902
krupp ist alleine
am nächsten Tag ist der Tod
die Todesursache ist umstritten bis
heute
es gibt kein Anzeichen dass er sich
selbst umgebracht haben soll das also
eine wirkliche wilde Behauptung die
durch nichts zu stützen ist wenn man
anfängt also forschen
doch letzte Zweifel bleiben auch in der
Familie Glauben Angehörige an Selbstmord
denke dass das schon so gewesen sein
kann eben weil dieses Homosexualität in
der Familie auch vorkommt nicht nur
einmal und das war natürlich in dem
ganzen Thema stolz Ehre selbst Anspruch
der damaligen Zeit ein fürchterliches
Coming-out und er hat vermutlich schon
er hat dann daraus die Konsequenz
gezogen hat gesagt ich kann mit diesem
Stigma nicht leben
Friedrich Alfred hinterlässt zwei
Töchter Barbara links Berta rechts im
Bild
das waren
pubertierende Backfische wirklich
ahnungslos und die mussten nun durch
diesen Skandal gebracht werden ohne dass
sie wirklich Schaden nahm viele Jahre
später hat Berta mal erzählt dass über
dieses Thema sie mit ihrer Mutter nie
geredet hat
die Villa Hügel ist jetzt in weiblicher
Art
Berta Grund die ältere der beiden
Schwestern wird die reichste Erbin
Deutschlands
die damit verbundene Unfreiheit lernt
die 16-jährige schnell kennen
denn das Werk ist zu wichtig für die
Mächtigen
der Kaiser will dass ein passender Mann
gefunden wird
die Wahl fällt auf einen Diplomaten
Gustav von Bohlen und Halbach ich weiß
nur dass er ja auch an wahnsinnig
disziplinierter Mann war glaube ich für
seine gesamte Existenz mit Berater
zusammen sicherlich immer ein Problem
hatte doch ein wenig zu beweisen dass er
Wörter nicht wegen des Vermögens das
Geld ist geheiratet hat und sicherlich
auch dadurch immer sein erster Mann sein
wollte
er will krupcher sein als ein Krupp
unter gustav ist alles nach der Uhr
geregelt jede Minute Pflicht und
Disziplin
als Firmenleiter darf sich Gustav nun
Krupp von Bohlen und Halbach nennen ich
glaube alle Beteiligten war froh dass
ein präsentabler junger Mann gefunden
war was ich besonders nett finde ist ist
also ohne Zweifel eine wilde und große
Liebe gewesen zwischen den beiden ist
davor steht die nächsten zehn Jahren
acht Schwangerschaften doch die erste
ist die wichtig
ste schon ein Jahr nach der Hochzeit
wird der Stammhalter geboren Alfred
ein fröhliches Kind noch
denn in der großen Villa Hügel ist für
menschliche Wärme kaum Platz
[Musik]
kommen Sie in eine Riesenhalle
das was sie also wollen wir mal sagen
wenn ich gerade sehr heimelig ist aber
da hängen lauter große Bilder meist von
der Familie als Kind haben wir im
zweiten Stock gewohnt also ziemlich
abgetrennt von
oberhalb von der oberen Halle aber
richtig wohl gefühlt haben wir uns nicht
es gab ja so gut wie keine persönlichen
Liebesbezeugung zwischen Eltern und
Kindern was Mama am Sonntag einfach ins
Bett der Eltern gekrochen kommt und dort
irgendwie ein Buch vorgelesen bekommt
oder so das gab es das unbedingt war
materiell fehlt es den Kindern an nichts
sie haben einen eigenen Park eigene
Reitpferde
aber keine Freiheit
die Kinder hatten feste Sprechstunden
bei ihren Eltern da stand dann Gustav
mit der Taschenuhr so als Stoppuhr jetzt
symbolisiert und dann wurden die Themen
die zu besprechen waren Erziehungsthemen
die wurden dann sage ich mal
einseitig besprochen um nicht zu sagen
diktiert
dabei trifft es den ältesten Alfred
besonders hart
kein Preußen Prinz ist strenger erzogen
worden Gouvernanten und Angestellte sind
auf Schritte und tritt präsent
bis zu seinem 15 Lebensjahr wird er von
Hauslehrern auf der Villa
hügelunterrichtet
Freunde hat er kaum er hat nur seine
Familie
er hat auch gesagt alles was ich getan
habe hat nicht selber von mir abgehangen
das ist immer von anderen bestimmt
worden und so ist aus ihm durch diese
Erziehung auf ein ganz bestimmtes Ziel
die Pflicht den Werk gegenüber zu
erfüllen nicht seine Bedürfnisse
auszuleben so hat diese Erziehung dazu
geführt dass er ein sehr verschlossener
Mensch geworden ist ein großer großer
Schweiger
1918 Deutschland hat den ersten
Weltkrieg verloren die Revolution bricht
aus
der Kaiser dankt ab die Wände trifft die
Krups schwer
die Firma steht vor dem Konkurs Waffen
darf sie nicht mehr produzieren
die Wirtschaftskrise trifft das ganze
Land Unruhen sind an der Tagesordnung
Nährboden für radikale Bewegungen
viele legen ihre Hoffnungen auf einen
der ihnen das Heil verspricht
[Applaus]
als Hitler die Macht übernimmt
hält sich in der Villa Hügel die
Begeisterung in Grenzen
[Musik]
proletarisch und sie war
entsetzt als die
Fahne mit den drei cobringen eingeholt
werden musste und die Hakenkreuzfahne
aufgezogen weil sie hat da sogar an
dieser Situation bei dieser Situation
geweint
[Musik]
1934 lebt der Rüpel sich selbst nach
Essen ein
Werksbesichtigung sein Ziel Kunde werden
auf der Villa Hügel doch dort ist nicht
jeder Kunde auch gleich ein König
Hitler wurde empfangen in Essen nicht in
der Hauptverwaltung und es wurde ihm im
wahrsten des Wortes großer Bahnhof
bereitet aber meine Großformat hat sich
ja geweigert ihm zu einem essensanfang
dieser Herr kommt mir nicht auf die Lüge
Hitler ist erzürnt doch der Zorn
verfliegt als bald natürlich war Hitler
auch ein
Verehrer der Kopfschmerzen
aber ein begeisterter Technik
und er hat weniger mit Gustav grob als
mit erich Müller
dem
kanonenexperten des Hauses grob sehr
intensive
Fachgespräche geführt
und Hitler fordert Waffen erstmals nach
jahrelanger Unterbrechung produziert
Krupp wieder rüstungsgüte im
konjunkturellen Aufschwung schreibt die
Firma wieder schwarze Zahlen
rüstet Gustav Krupp weil es die
Obrigkeit verlangt
[Musik]
es fährt so zu sagen wie weit die Taktik
geht
und wo die Überzeugung dann anfängt
später ist grob immer mehr davon
überzeugt dass die Regierung Hitler für
Deutschland ein
Gewinn ist
der junge Student Alfred hat mit dem
Nationalsozialismus kaum Berührungen
fern von Essen von den Pflichten und
Zwängen des Elternhauses genießt er die
freie Zeit
[Musik]
der Sportbegeisterte nimmt 1936 an den
Olympischen Spielen teil er gewinnt im
Segeln die Bronze Medaille und lernt
eine Frau kennen
Anneliese bar
ja das Problem war Anneliese war ja
schon eine geschiedene Frau und sie ist
seit schwanger geworden ungewollt also
jedenfalls war es nicht geplant und er
hat dann die Konsequenzen gezogen hat
gesagt er heiratet sie es hat sie
geheiratet weiß ich schon schwanger war
dass davon natürlich seine Eltern nicht
so schrecklich begeistert waren das kann
man sich natürlich vorstellen
die dünne auf dem Familienfoto trügt
also es war ja nicht nur ein subtiles
Gefühl sondern es war ja offen
ausgetragener Krieg der dort
stattgefunden hat also
Alfred musste mit seiner jungen Frau ins
Nebengebäude ziehen und durfte als
ältester Sohn nicht mehr im Hauptgebäude
mit ihr wohnen ähm Anneliese ist zu
vielen Veranstaltungen und
Gesellschaften nicht eingeladen gewesen
obwohl sie die Frau des ältesten Sohnes
war die Isolation innerhalb der Familie
wird immer größer
den Schwiegereltern ist noch ein
weiterer Umstand ein Dorn im Auge
denn Anneliese hat ein Problem
mit dem Alkohol
das ist natürlich dann die Katze die
sich in den Schwanz beißt die Spirale
führt nach unten je mehr sie trinkt
desto weniger wird sie natürlich geladen
oder gerne gesehen und dementsprechend
hat sich das natürlich dann auch sehr
schnell verselbstständigt
[Musik]
doch die Missachtung trifft nicht nur
Anneliese sondern auch Ihr Kind den
kleinen Arndt dieses Kind ist an sich
nicht von den Großeltern gewünscht und
einer Angestellte
hat
zur Berta kurze Oma Krupp gesagt Arndt
ist doch ein hübsches Kind und da hat
die Bertha guckt sie angeherrscht Arndt
ist für mich kein richtiges Kind
über seine Großmutter schreibt Arndt
später in sein Tagebuch sie sei eine
alte einsame Frau beherrscht von den
Intrigen sie war schuld und befahl ihrem
Sohn sich von seiner Gattin zu scheiden
deren Leben am Reichtum zerbrach
Berta setzt sich durch ihr Sohn Alfred
lässt sich scheiden
der Alfred hätte sich mit seiner Mutter
nicht angelegt das war für ihn keine
Option zu sagen Mama das ist mein Leben
es ist meine Frau es ist mein Kind ist
mein Glück ja hier hast du nicht rum zu
fischen das hat nicht gepasst das haben
die Eltern klar gemacht
unmissverständlich Alfred beugt sich den
Familienwerten Pflicht und Gehorsam
und seiner Karriere steht nichts mehr im
Weg als Juniorchef erhält er einen Sitz
im Direktorium der Firma
[Musik]
Hitlers Krieg beginnt auch mit
kopfschematerial
Polen wird überrollt in nur fünf Wochen
[Musik]
mit dem Krieg zieht ein neuer Geist in
das Unternehmen ein
[Musik]
bitte Beginn des Krieges ist für
Gustav Krupp
eine distanzierte Haltung
nicht mehr möglich weil er weiß dass
jede innere Distanz und jede Kritik
nicht mehr angemessen sein der Firma
werden vom Regime soll Zahlen vorgelegt
die Wehrmacht bestimmt was produziert
wird
doch bald ist die Zeit der blitzsiege
vorbei immer mehr deutsche Männer müssen
an die Front darunter auch tausende von
krupparbeitern die Verluste steigen
auch die Familie Krupp verliert Söhne
Klaus
Eckbert
[Musik]
der Firma gehen langsam die
Arbeitskräfte aus
die Produktion droht zu erliegen
[Musik]
Ersatz bietet das Regime russische
Kriegsgefangene und Zwangsarbeiter sie
sollen die Lücken schließen doch bei
Krupp ist man nicht begeistert natürlich
haben wir viel versucht zu bremsen ja
gerade diese ganze Beschäftigung von
auslandsarbeitern und Füßen dagegen
gewehrt aber es war nichts zu machen
doch bei Krupp will man die soll Zahlen
erreichen und nimmt die Zwangsarbeiter
im gesamten Krieg sind es über 5
Millionen die ins Deutsche Reich
verschleppt werden
150.000 kommen zu Krupp über 100
Arbeitslager werden für die Firma
eingerichtet
für die Nazis sind die Russen
Untermenschen sie gestehen Ihnen nur
hungerrationen zu ein gruppenarbeiter
schreibt am 18 märz 1942 das ganze Essen
war buchstäblich nur Wasser es geht
nicht an dass die Leute uns hier bei der
Arbeit verrecken die Leute sollen hier
für uns arbeiten gut aber dann muss auch
dafür gesorgt werden
ich habe hier verschiedene Gestalten im
Lager gesehen da ist mir tatsächlich ein
kalter Schauer über den Buckel gelaufen
[Musik]
Zustände in den Lagern sie ähneln
Bildern wie diesen
auch die Konzernspitze weiß um die
Verhältnisse
sind sie denn überhaupt irgendwann mal
während des Krieges mit Fremdarbeitern
persönlichen Lagern gewesen
und haben sie da festgestellt dass es
wirklich so schlecht war
stellenweise war schlecht wir haben
darum gekämpft zusätzlich den Leuten
geben die wollen ja von da was essen
vorher betreut und wie sich das nannte
betreut und versorgt durch eine
besondere Organisation diese Versorgung
war teilweise schlecht werden und
versucht sie zu verbessern
zunächst nicht zulässig
getan wir haben Lebensmittel sogar
geschmuggelt aus Holland
Ende 1943 verschlechtert sich der
Gesundheitszustand von Vater Gustav
rapide
mit 73 Jahren beschließt er die Leitung
der Firma abzugeben
Alfred wird jetzt Herrscher über das
Krupp Imperium als alleiniger Inhaber
muss er für alles gerade stehen was im
Namen Krupp geschieht
[Musik]
die letzten Tage des Dritten Reiches
alle Fronten brechen zusammen
für die Panzerproduktion schickt das
Regime nach Essen was ihm noch zur
Verfügung steht
[Musik]
Minderjährige jüdische Mädchen aus
Auschwitz
[Musik]
eines Tages kamen es waren vielleicht
zwei drei oder vier Herren und wir
mussten uns aufstellen
und 500 von den 2000 Mädchen wurden nach
Essen mitgenommen
[Musik]
der SS
täglich werden sie zur Arbeit in die
Krupp Werke getrieben
wir dachten nur bekommen wir zu essen
oder hungern wir lassen Sie uns am Leben
oder töten Sie uns
dabei ist die Rettung nicht mehr fern im
März 45 ist Essen schon in Reichweite
der amerikanischen Artillerie
es sind nur noch wenige Kilometer doch
für die Jüdinnen soll es keine Rettung
geben
[Musik]
wir hatten nichts zu verlieren und
dachten sogar an flucht weil ein Junge
SS-Mann und sagte ihr kommt hier nicht
lebend raus die fünf Minuten euch alle
zu erschießen die haben wir immer
in der Hauptverwaltung sind die
Mordpläne der SS bekannt um ein Massaker
auf dem Werksgelände zu verhindern
beschließt das Direktorium die Mädchen
abzuschieben die SS übernimmt
zuletzt arbeitet Alfred für das Regime
bleibt aber auf Distanz
er ist
sehr extrem verschlossen und
zurückhalten und erfüllt damit auch
nicht die Hoffnungen die man gerade auch
von politischer Seite hingesetzt hat er
war einfach nicht
rücksichtslos genug nicht brutal genug
nicht entschlossen genug
doch die Alliierten sehen in ihm einen
wichtigen Förderer und Nutznießer der
Nazis als sie in Essen einmarschieren
haben sie ein Ziel den aus ihrer Sicht
mächtigsten deutschen Industriellen
verhaften
[Musik]
Alfred Arns flüchtet jedoch nicht
er stellt sich
das Bedürfnis nach Bestrafung bei den
Siegern ist es groß für sie sind alle
Krups Kriegsverbrecher
die krup-familie unterstützte mit
anderen industriellen Hitler sie
produzierten die Waffen für seine
Weltherrschaft jetzt haben wir sie
eingesperrt diese Familie war schon
Waffenschmied in Deutsch-Französischen
Krieg im Ersten Weltkrieg bauten sie
große Geschütze und U-Boote für den
Kaiser sie sind für den Tod von
alliierten Soldaten genauso schuldig wie
Hitler und Göring denn durch töten
verdienten sie ihr Geld
Alfred soll in Nürnberg büsen für den
Namen Krupp
obwohl ihm in keinem Anklagepunkt
individuelle Schuld nachgewiesen wird
lastet doch Verantwortung auf ihn
er erhält 12 Jahre Haft
in der Urteilsbegründung wurde den
Angeklagten insbesondere systematische
Plünderung ausländischen Eigentums und
menschenunwürdige Behandlung von
zivilarbeitern und Kriegsgefangenen zur
Last gelegt Alfred Krupps gesamtes
Vermögen einschließlich der kopfwerke
fällt der Beschlagnahme
[Musik]
ein junger
us-selfried wie er angesprochen werden
will Herr von Bohlen oder mit vollem
Namen Herr Krupp von Bohlen und Halbach
seine Antwort nennen sie mich grob wegen
dieses Namens bin ich hier und diese
Zelle ist mein Anteil an dem großen grob
Erbe
auch das Familienschloss blütenbach in
Österreich wird von den Amerikanern
besetzt
sie hatten Anneliese und der kleine
Arndt nach der Scheidung zu Flucht
genommen
nun müssen sie das Schloss verlassen
und da fragt der sieben ihre Art seine
Mutter
warum können wir denn nicht in Grünbach
bleiben hier ist es doch so schön warum
müssen wir dann weggehen und dann sagt
sie wir müssen fliehen es geht nicht
hier zu bleiben denn du bist ein Grund
und da sagte was ist denn ein Krupp und
da sagt zu ihm das ist etwas ganz ganz
furchtbares
schon früh instrumentalisiert die Mutter
das Kind
erzähl unter seiner Mutter gelitten der
Hand war vielleicht ein bisschen das
Faust Faust fand von Anneliese er war ja
wirklich der einzige Gruppe
Sohn und Erbe und da sie ja schon sehr
früh geschieden wurde das war so ihr
fand sie das war auch ihr kleiner
Zahlmeister es war ihr Ehemann Ersatz
Ernst kommt in ein Internat nach
Oberbayern
das als sein Vater bekommt er die Chance
unter Gleichaltrigen aufzuwachsen
eigentlich hat er uns eher ein bisschen
leid getan weil wir wussten dass sein
Vater noch im Gefängnis ist
eher von seiner Mutter getrennt wurde
die hier durchaus regelmäßig auftauchte
und es ihm das Leben unserer Meinung
nach damals nicht leichter gemacht hat
in dem Moment wo er anfing bisschen in
der Gruppe aufzugehen erschien wieder
die Mutter und hat ihm irgendwelche
Privilegien verschafft was in an so
einer Gesellschaft und so einer
Gemeinschaft schwierig ist
Bernd zieht sich zurück er wird zum
Einzelgängern und will kein Gruppen mehr
sein
er konnte dass er innerlich ich sehe uns
oft noch da so in der Klasse sitzen
Pause man wollte nicht rausgehen dann
zeichnete er und er sagte dann ach ich
wäre vielleicht Modezeichner oder so
etwas ja
inzwischen ändern sich die Vorzeichen
1951 der Kalte Krieg hat begonnen die
Alliierten haben nun Interesse an einem
starken Westdeutschland viele Urteile
werden revidiert der amerikanische Hohe
Kommissar John mcloy prüft auch den Kopf
Fall noch einmal
[Musik]
ich hatte nie das Gefühl dass mein Vater
seine Entscheidung später bereute
für ihn war Alfred nicht verantwortlich
für das was in den kropfwerken an
Verbrechen geschah
ja er hat den Fall sehr sorgsam
überprüft
am 2 februar 1951 kommt Alfred Krupp
frei
aber sechs Jahre Haft haben Spuren
hinterlassen
es war sehr traurig im ganzen und er
konnte aus sich ja auch nicht ausdrücken
er musste einfach
hat nicht gelächelt und das hat ihn
eigentlich noch sehr werter gemacht als
wir er vorher war
sein erster Besuch in der Freiheit gilt
Arnd für beide seit Jahren die erste
Gelegenheit zu einem Vater Sohn Gespräch
und die beiden gingen im Schulhof vor
aller Augen um ein Rondell immer wieder
ganz lange es gibt die schönsten
Spaziergänge dort in Oberbayern aber
ausgerechnet vor alle Augen gingen die
und hatte nicht das Gefühl Vater und
Sohn zu sehen sondern eher Herr und
Knecht
denn der Vater sieht in seinem Sohn
nicht das Kind sondern den Nachfolger
da ist eigentlich die normale Reaktion
warum hat er ihn nicht mal in den Arm
genommen
und ich denke das wäre auch die
Sehnsucht von dem Abend gewesen
Arndt flüchtet sich in einen Traumwelt
spielt Theater
er dreht sogar einen eigenen Film
über die Liebe in der Pubertät
und dabei stellt er fest dass er sich
für Frauen nicht interessiert
in sein Tagebuch schreibt er
manchmal denke ich das Sterben sei gar
nicht so schlimm
mein Leben ist total verpfuscht durch
meine Anlagen
dann hat er sich eben
zurückgezogen hat im Internat noch ein
internen Kreis gebildet also
viele jüngere Knaben um sich versammelt
die weich waren mädchenhaft waren
er soll auch mal erwischt worden sein
und muss die Schule wechseln sein Abitur
macht Arndt in der Schweiz
[Musik]
danach studiert er auf Wunsch des Vaters
BWL gegen seinen Willen
doch dafür wird er in die Familie
aufgenommen
der Kronprinz darf jetzt sogar neben
Großmutter Berta sitzen
und quält sich
ja das ist mein Sohn 23 Jahre alt er ist
noch nicht in der Firma tätig aber er
studierte in Köln Betriebswirtschaft und
wir da einmal das Werk übernehmen ich
hoffe dass es einmal übernehmen wird
Mitte der 50er Jahre versucht Alfred den
angeschlagenen Ruf der Firma
wiederherzustellen nie mehr will er eine
Waffe produzieren die Firma soll ein
neues Gesicht bekommen
dafür holt er sich einen Manager an die
Seite der ihm hilft die Firma neu zu
strukturieren
Berthold Balz
Alfred hat er zwar die Entscheidungen
die entscheidende Dinge nach wie vor
selbstbestimmt aber er hat das
Tagesgeschäft doch abgegeben also diese
Bewegung weg von der Firma war
gleichzeitig eine Bewegung hin zu seinem
privaten Leben
Alfred unternimmt ausgedehnte Segeltörns
oft ist er wochenlang auf hoher See
[Musik]
und sucht das einfache Leben
an Bord will er Kamerad sein
doch als eigener des Schiffes hat er
auch mitten auf dem Atlantik eine
Sonderstellung
er heiratet ein zweites Mal Vera
Hosenfeld
doch auch diese Ehe scheitert
bleibt ein Einzelgänger
danach hat er niemanden mehr gehabt also
überhaupt niemanden mehr sondern allein
in seinem Haus hat er das ist sehr
schöne Haus da im hügelpark gebaut ganz
modern und da ist er dann doch sehr
einsam gewesen
nicht weit entfernt von der Villa Hügel
sorgt sich Alfred Krupp von Bohlen und
Halbach Mitte der 60er Jahre um den
Fortbestand der Firma
denn seine Gesundheit ist angegriffen
[Musik]
Herr raucht er war ja ein Kettenraucher
und das machte uns immer Sorgen eine
Zigarette wurde an der nächsten
angezündet
und auch das ganze Haus roch eben wenn
man da eintrat nach Zigarettenrauch
april 1967
Alfred weiß dass er nicht mehr lange
leben wird
Lungenkrebs
sein letztes Ziel ist die Firma und sein
Privatvermögen in eine Stiftung zu
überführen
weil er weiß dass sein Sohn nicht der
richtige Nachfolge ist doch offen
spricht er mit Ernst darüber nicht
[Musik]
ich denke der Alfred wollte das Gespräch
und konnte es nicht führen ich glaube
aber auch dass der Arm das Gespräch mit
seinem Vater gar nicht hätte führen
können
es ist Bertholds der Ernst davon
überzeugt auf sein Erbe für eine hohe
Abfindung zu verzichten
das ist eigentlich so der tragische
Schlusspunkt unter einer tragischen
Beziehung muss man eigentlich sagen ich
meines vatersohn Beziehung aber damit
auch sinnbildlich unter der ganzen
Schlusspunkt an der unter die ganze
Familiengeschichte weil das dann ja auch
der Beginn war das Übergangs in eine
Stiftung die mit dem familiengedanken ja
gar nichts mehr zu tun hat
aber es ist Alfreds letzter Wille
Familie und Firma werden getrennt
diesen Weg zu gehen ermöglichte mein
Sohn Arndt durch seinen Erbverzicht
für seine verantwortungsbereiter
Einsicht möchte ich ihm vor aller
Öffentlichkeit ausdrücklich danken möge
es ihnen vor gönnt sein die weitere
Entwicklung unserer Firma noch viele
Jahre mit zu gestalten und mit zu
verfolgen Glückauf
150 Jahre lang waren Firma und Familie
eins der Name Krupp geriet zum Mythos
die Marke bleibt doch der Familienname
er erlischt mit Alfred Tod nur wer das
Unternehmen führt darf seinen Namen
Krupp
[Musik]
mit Alfred Krupp von Bohlen und Halbach
stirbt am 30 Juli 1967 auch der letzte
Krupp
sein Sohn Arndt darf den Namen nicht
mehr führen
ich glaube sicher dass ein sehr verehrt
hat er hat er hat mir immer gesagt in
meine überragende Persönlichkeit und hat
den Buben verschriften denke ich mir
also er hat den sicher sicher sehr gern
gehabt aber er hat den gefürchtet
für armt beginnt ein neues Leben
jetzt bricht er mit der Familie mit den
noch lebenden Onkeln und Tanten
und er bricht mit sämtlichen
Familientraditionen
er rebelliert einfach gegen alles was
diese Familie ihm auf oktrouiert hat und
ihm angetan hat und er tut es halt auf
seine Art um einfach nach außen hin zu
zeigen jetzt mache ich das was ich will
und ich werde jetzt nicht mehr von
dieser Film Familie mir wird nicht mehr
gesagt was ich machen muss und was meine
Pflicht ist und
ja was so lange in dieser Familie
hoch gehalten wurde das hatte im
Endeffekt dann in der Öffentlichkeit
gezielt meines Erachtens auch dann
zerstört
Arndt taucht ab in das Leben des Jetset
heiratet sogar seine beste Freundin doch
eine richtige Ehe ist es nicht er will
der Herrschaft der Mutter entgehen
die sich an ihn klammert ein Leben lang
fast gefährliche Frau sehr gescheit sehr
gut ausschauen
aber herzlos
am Ende wird sie ihn sogar für Geld
erpressen
mit Details aus seinem Privatleben
Armut durchlebt die Prophezeiung die er
schon als 16-Jährige machte den Fluch
des Geldes
[Musik]
schlösserhäuser
Dinge eigentlich als transitorisch ich
betrachte Geld
ist alle Menschen geborgt für die Zeit
die erlebt und ich verstehe Menschen
nicht die sich zum Sklaven des Geldes
war
Ernst flüchtet in seine Fabelwelt am
Ende lässt er sich sogar zum Ritter
schlagen da ist er schon sterbenskrank
mundbodenkrebs
[Musik]
als er sagte nur er hat einen Auftrag
für mich
er wollte noch mal als König gemalt sein
ja er macht dann safe auf und holte eine
Krone raus und die setzte er sich also
auf und die war richtig schwer sein und
er war schon richtig geschwächt der
konnte mir gerade stehen also lief die
Schweißperlen liefen eben von der Stirn
runter und er spürte auch dass es
irgendwo zu Ende geht und das sein Traum
wenigsten manifestiert ist das
dass er der Nachwelt als König gehalten
bleibt
ein König ohne Königreich früh hatte er
auf das stahlimperium verzichtet und den
Namen Krupp verloren doch zeitlebens sah
er das immer anders
[Musik]
grob vom Bohlen und Halbach hat er
geschrieben hat er selber geschrieben so
soll die Todesanzeige sein und ich finde
es auch richtig
[Musik]
das kann ihm keiner nehmen das ist der
letzte Gruppe war
der erste der sich frei gemacht hat von
den Zwängen seiner Vorfahren
grob Mythos und Wahrheit einer deutschen
Familie
[Musik]